hello I was Tokyo unos Los Angeles
Montes and Sasha are both reporting the
latest auto show news but their
continents apart montes is in Tokyo
while sasha is getting the lowdown in LA
on this thing I'm be on zalga titans
enough biden's august this dish about so
sonship are we gonna stick around here
all day or shall we go inside mine I'm
just waiting for you Matt this done well
then let's go inside Alice Lowe the
tokyo auto show is something of a home
match for japanese carmakers of course
what's that's like its mazda for example
is presenting two different powertrain
variations of the mazda3 known over here
is axilla there is a natural gas version
and a hybrid you can't tell from looking
that this is a hybrid model the only
giveaway is a little badge on the rear
hinting at what's under the hood the
hybrid technology is from Toyota and was
adapted by mazda zone engineers
Coulson gone yesterday the big German
names are represented here too of course
taking center stage at the Porsche stand
is not the custom sports car but it's a
new compact SUV on the other side of the
Pacific sasha is likewise inspecting the
new McCann it was in LA that it had its
world premiere the McCann is the fifth
model line Porsche has launched it's
aimed at drivers looking for a sporty
compact SUV its standard fitted with
all-wheel drive while the new 3.6 liter
v6 bi-turbo engine catapults the car
from 0 to 100 km/h and 4.8 seconds
these are several listen this Chevrolet
Silverado is exactly the right car for
American roads sasha reckons big is
still beautiful here and gas prices
aren't as high as elsewhere the
Silverado has plenty of space for extra
cargo that would fill you up on Chester
but it's not so ideal for the japanese
market mattis points out over here you
need alternative mobility concepts such
as the VW twin up it looks like the
regular up compact car but underneath it
has the engineering of the xl1
the twin up combines a 36 kilowatt
diesel engine with a 36 kilowatt
electric motor VW calls it a 1 liter per
hundred kilometer car for the whole
family and despite the poor aerodynamics
it apparently really does guzzle only
minimally more than the xl1 two-seater
in LA BW presented the road ready design
vision GTI 370 kilowatts of power take
the muscular hatchback from zero to 100
in just 3.9 seconds top speed is just
beyond the 300 kilometer per hour mark
back to Japan and the electrically
powered BMW i3 it's set to hit Japanese
showrooms in 2014
dr. these fictitious Markus wants to
know how important electromobility is to
BWW in places like Japan the Japanese
market is incredibly technology oriented
replies the BMW R&D chief hybrids
already account for 20 plus percent of
sales here Japanese customers are very
receptive to new technologies plus
urbanization is quite advanced here over
seventy percent of people in Japan
already live in major conurbations and
this is the market that the I brand was
made for BMW believes that it will have
one of the chief sales markets in Japan
la affinity of all at famous sunshine in
California open-top driving is very
popular in the Golden State sasha is
sitting in a z4 but BMW also has a new
convertible version of the 4 series on
show this is the second model in the
relatively young four series its steel
folding roof makes it a sound option for
colder regions to the highlight is right
behind me here is the 4-series
convertible it's the world premiere it's
lower its wider it's slightly longer
it's a great looking car ride quality is
high thanks to the optional xdrive
all-wheel drive system and the neck
warmers for front seat occupants at
extra comfort and cooler times of the
year
la has also hosted a world premiere for
a BMW subsidiary behold the fully
redesigned version of the mini cooper
hardtop
nice phenomena nothing from the old many
was retained explains the brands boss he
praises the work his team did on both
the interior and exterior further
evolving the iconic design plus the
technology under the hood there you have
the new three and four-cylinder engines
twenty-seven percent less fuel
consumption combined with ten percent
more output the launch of this car is
good news he says I'm in this out of
muffin many fans and other
individualists can look forward to this
latest milestone and the german british
joint venture and tokyo that blue baby
behind montes is called the toyota fcv
concept this is a hydrogen powered car
scheduled for volume production in 2015
the design appears to need some work but
the engineering is more or less complete
the only real problem facing its makers
is the lack of infrastructure Toyota's
Derek royer brings up the which came
first scenario the chicken or the egg we
say first you need a chicken so that
somebody can carry on making the eggs in
this case filling stations so we're
encouraging an expansion of the
infrastructure we've signed commitments
to fuel cell vehicles for Northern
Europe as we have done in Japan too if I
say that these vehicles are on their way
that gives builders and operators of gas
stations the security they need to
continue the tour of their victims tisha
heightened as it stands for that one
so that's fine so it's goodbye for
montes at the tokyo motor show and
goodbye from sasha in LA they have an
ocean and half the planet between them
and they both have a 12 / flight home to
Germany so bon voyage deutschland alles
clown good the fluke